[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mercredi 1er
février
identification biométrique images
infrarouges encore reconnaissance
faciale comment assurer la sécurité dans
les villes du futur une conférence a
réuni experts et spécialistes du sujet à
guyancourt
certains s'en méfient encore et pourtant
ils sont de plus en plus utilisé par les
français les médicaments génériques
représentent 82% des produits délivrés
en pharmacie dans les yvelines
une nouvelle campagne de communication
vise à combattre les derniers freins à
leur utilisation
enfin dans ce journal vous ferez la
connaissance de charline kohnen
yvelinoise de 23 ans qui va participer
bientôt à la finale nationale du
concours miss élégance mais on débute ce
journal avec le musée de la ville de
saint quentin en yvelines qui a
officiellement rouvert ses portes ce
mardi soir à montigny le bretonneux
après les discours le traditionnel ruban
a été coupé par les élus environ 120
personnes étaient présentes pour
l'occasion et ont pu visiter la
structure de 280 m²
désormais installé dans le bâtiment de
la médiathèque du canal les visiteurs du
soir ont également découvert une
exposition permanente sur l'histoire de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines écouter ces quelques réactions
au micro de notre journaliste michael et
demi d'eau moi je crois que c'est
important parce que justement on est
issu d'une nuit de nouvelles on a
l'impression qui a jamais eu de vie
avant et là on fait le lien entre les
villages skis et la nuit de
et ce qui est la vie de maintenant c'est
vraiment l'objectif c'est cette
transmission du savoir de la
connaissance mais aussi du partage
on n'est pas là pour donner des leçons
d'histoire on est là pour la construire
avec les habitants et avec les élus on
est ravis d'ailleurs de leur soutien
dix-huit mois de travaux
ça valait la peine une journée
d'information et des changes sur la
sécurité dans les zones urbaines
l'association opticsvalley a organisé
hier dans la salle de conférence du
crédit agricole à guyancourt un
séminaire sur la problématique de la
cyber sécurité dans la ville
intelligente professionnels et
spécialistes se sont ainsi succédé toute
la journée pour présenter des projets
innovants le but assurer à sa sécurité
face aux cyberattaques reportage
d'haussmann vendeurs des toute la
journée des directeurs d'entreprise de
cybersécurité ont défilé au pupitre pour
défendre leur projet le but améliorer la
sécurité les entreprises selon une étude
opinionway 80% des sociétés françaises
ont été visés par une cyberattaque en
pour jonathan bene l'un des
organisateurs de l'événement dans une
ville intelligente la cybersécurité
devenu incontournable au regard
notamment de l'actualité les actes
terroristes de l'année 2015 en
particulier mais aussi et surtout parce
que la sécurité constitue l'un des
marchés applicatifs
les plus intéressants et les plus
dynamiques pour les technologies
optiques et photoniques dont
opticsvalley se charge de l'animation de
la filière
donc ça nous paraissait assez naturel au
regard de l'actualité et de ses
opportunités de marché d'exploiter et
puis d'explorer la thématique à travers
ce séminaire est pour lutter contre les
actes malveillants le public présent a
pu découvrir des technologie infrarouge
des lasers accordables miniaturisés ou
encore l'identification des individus
par biométrie des technologies qui ne
sont pas encore en vente sur le marché
on le voit bien demain si vous la
démocratie
ce fait part par internet au moment du
raid ou intérêt quand même à veiller à
ce que ça se passe bien vous voyez bien
la sécurité aussi pour les entreprises
qui sont en concurrence d'une entrevue
qu'il faut sécuriser un minium de
données donc c'est un marché qui monte
très fortement dans laquelle saint
quentin est très présent par ces
entreprises dans les années à venir le
budget des entreprises consacrées à la
cybersécurité devrait atteindre 10%
d'autres séminaires seront organisés
durant l'année 2010 est à saint quentin
en yvelines
c'est un outil qui devrait simplifier le
travail de la justice depuis le 1er
janvier tous les actes d'une procédure
en cours avec une juridiction
administrative doivent être déposées via
le site internet télé recours son accès
est pour l'instant réservée aux avocats
et aux administrations
mais devrait bientôt s'ouvrir aux
particuliers reportage alors l'envié
plus de papier plus de timbres la
justice dématérialise l'utilisation du
site internet télé recours est désormais
obligatoire pour communiquer avec la
juridiction administrative saisie
toutes les pièces du dossier sont
concernés depuis le dépôt de requête à
la décision finale des recours et la
possibilité de saisir la juridiction
administrative par voie dématérialisée
au lieu d'avoir à déposer un courrier à
la franchir à faire des copies de
documents il est possible depuis le 1er
janvier de saisir les tribunaux
administratifs les cours administratives
d'appel et le conseil d'état par un
courrier électronique
mais attention selle les avocats et les
administrations concernées peuvent
utiliser ce site fermé pour l'instant
aux particuliers cela permet pour la
juridiction mais comme pour les
requérants tous les cas les avocats et
tous les acteurs publics on veut parler
des économies en termes de papier en
termes de frais d'affranchissement
cette dématérialisation présente
toutefois un avantage pour le
particulier hauteur de la requête celui
de fluidifier les échanges entre les
parties et donc probablement de gagner
du temps télé recours facilite le
travail des juridictions et par là peut
contribuer à la réduction des délais de
jugement
et qui sont eux-mêmes aujourd'hui
maîtrisée de voir l'ensemble des
juridictions administratives puisque aux
trois niveaux le tribunal sera tive en
première instance la cour administrative
d'appel et le conseil d'état en dernier
ressort les délais moyens sont partout
inférieures à une année les particuliers
qui souhaitent se passer d'avocats
doivent encore envoyer tous leurs
documents par courrier mais plus pour
très longtemps
l'administration judiciaire devrait
bientôt leur ouvrir l'accès au site
ils se sont largement imposés dans la
vie des français avec le temps ils ce
sont les médicaments génériques utilisé
pour soigner les maux les plus bénins
comme les mots elle les plus graves
aujourd'hui huit français sur dix les
utiliser pour séduire les derniers
récalcitrants
la caisse primaire d'assurance maladie
des yvelines lance une opération de
communication
reportage de mathilde mihalis deschamps
et pierrick bouillon dérivé du
médicament princeps le générique
pourtant 20 à 60% moins cher que le
produit d'origine ne séduit pas encore
tous les français pharmaciens et
médecins s'unissent à lever les derniers
freins à la prise de ces médicaments
le patient on se rend compte que
certains médicaments agissent autrement
je prends l'exemple du paracétamol en
fonction de la manière dont il est
administré en comprimés ou gélules
en tout ce qu'on voudra et mal la
vitesse à laquelle le médicament agit et
la durée d'action varie d'une personne à
une autre
convaincre son patient de prendre un
générique lui apporter des informations
précises c'est le défi quotidien des
professionnels de santé et de la
campagne de promotion il faut que le
pharmacien le médecin soit déjà
convaincus eux mêmes que les produits
sont similaires à 99% d'entre eux au
médicament qui a fait ses preuves
pendant dix ans qui est le médicament
princeps pour les aider une campagne
publicitaire vient consolider la
confiance et la connaissance de ces
médicaments
un moyen compréhensible qui lève le
doute sur ses génériques
ils permettent
d'une façon compréhensible par tout le
monde de comprendre que c'est un enjeu
pour pour l'ensemble des patients et qui
a une réelle sécurité de ces produits là
voilà j'ai qu'on peut traiter toutes les
maladies les plus bénigne au plus grave
avec les médicaments génériques
c'est ça qui est important à l'avenir la
caisse primaire d'assurance maladie
prévoit comme objectif une prise de
médicaments génériques dont 86% des cas
en octobre dernier elle remporté le
titre de miss élégance paris ile de
france elle vise désormais le titre
national charline conan 23 ans vit à
saint cyr l'école et participera à la
finale du concours de beauté le 11
février prochain
nous avons rencontré cette jeune femme
de 23 ans qui souhaite devenir plus tard
professeur de danse son portrait par
nicolas landry et camille lambert de
grands yeux noisette une chevelure
volumineuse et un sourire gracieux des
atouts qui ont fait de charline conan
miss élégance paris ile de france à 23
ans elle est arrivée première du
concours régional face à neuf autres
candidates une compétition sur la beauté
mais pas seulement
c'est un concours de beauté qui
est ouvert aux jeunes filles de d'un
mètre 65 ce qui est différent des autres
qui sont ouverts qu'à partir de 70 et
qui met d'abord en avant l'élégance la
beauté bien sûr mais surtout l'élégance
le port de tête le sourire la démarche a
tenu le 11 février charline disputera la
finale nationale
passionnée de danse depuis son enfance
elle mise en partie sur sa formation
pour remporter la couronne je suis
actuellement en école de danse
professionnelle sur paris c'est dans le
but final d'obtenir mon diplôme d'état
de professeur de danse ça aide parce que
mon de pages d'une formation plus
classique qui donc du coup se tenir
droit avoir un port de tête
être gracieuse voilà c'est des choses
qui m'ont aidé beaucoup grâce à danse
classique en dehors de ses études elle
passe du temps chez sa mère avec sa
soeur aux mines il st denis
des moments privilégiés qui lui apporte
un soutien infaillible
je l'aide dans le choix de ses tenues je
l'aide quand elle fait des petites
vidéos elle mon sang mon avis moi je
pense que c'est super parce que c'est
quelque chose qu'on fait pas souvent que
tout le monde ne peut pas faire et donc
je pense que c'est quelque chose
d'unique
la finale se déroulera à forges-les-eaux
en normandie
les internautes ont encore jusqu'au 10
février pour voter pour leur candidate
favorite sur le site du coucou on
referme ce journal avec la signature ce
matin la fondation ag2r à paris d'une
convention entre les écoles de la
deuxième chance des yvelines et du val
de marne et l'association j'ai un rêve
une association créée par la championne
d'europe de natation synchronisée muriel
hermine
le but de ce partenariat proposé un
coaching de haut niveau à des jeunes
sans diplôme les précisions avec
haussmann vendeurs d et julie à barenton
bout du travail sens de l'effort ou
encore persévérance voilà ce que les
élèves de l'école de la seconde chance
vont apprendre grâce au coaching de l'ex
championne d'europe de natation
synchronisée
muriel hermine spécialiste du coaching
en entreprise depuis la fin de sa
carrière
l'ex nageuse souhaite soutenir les
jeunes en difficulté moi je les
questionne parce que je considère qu'ils
ont les réponses aux questions qu'ils se
posent et aux difficultés qu'ils
rencontrent j'ai pas les solutions mais
eux en les solutions les amener à
prendre conscience de certaines choses à
regarder d'autres choses différemment
sous un autre angle et finalement ouvrir
des fenêtres dans leur tête et c'est des
moments émotionnels des moments
j'utilise des outils de coaching et de
formation
qui sont vraiment très intéressant et
très très pointue et pour permettre à
ces jeunes de se dépasser douze
adolescents partent pendant deux jours
et une nuit dans la ville de fondettes
dans le centre de la france
là ils seront encadrés par une équipe de
cinq personnes qui les pousseront lors
d'activités sportives comme de l'
escalade ou encore de la natation
une expérience qui a déjà porté ses
fruits lors d'une session test en
décembre 2016 les jeunes qui ont connu
un début de vie souvent compliqué qui
ont besoin de cette deuxième chance
reprennent confiance et ceux qui sont
revenus de ce premier stage mais de la
même manière ceux qui avaient assisté
aussi à la première conférence et ont
puisé une très très grande énergie et
c'est pour ça que ce qu'on signe
aujourd'hui on le signe de manière tout
à fait sereine et à l'issue des deux
jours l'association de muriel hermine
accompagne financièrement les jeunes en
les soutenant dans la mise en place d'un
projet professionnel
pour cette première saison 4 aux
sessions de coaching sont prévues entre
janvier et juin 2010 cette fin de ce 7 8
le journal rendez vous demain jeudi aux
horaires habituels pour une nouvelle
édition d'ici là tous nos reportages
sont à retrouver sur notre site internet
et mes fils 78 points comme et
l'application tv fil 78 bonne soirée à
tous
[Musique]